finally I'm here so happy and very
excited that you decided to join my
adventure which is titled breaking the
norm with creative and this is the price
CSS yay thank you okay so I have to
share my story one day I got a task
create a website well I did it for a
living
easy right but actually I was stuck like
I I was lacking creative powers I didn't
know what to do it was a huge blocker so
yeah I literally was lying on my desk
and I was like what should I do
so I decided just to take a big breath
and just look on the website that I
visit daily it was people
it was Evernote section they all
together they looked like this you have
to admit that they're quite boring and
my friend she wanted to be funny she
sent me this link it was like yeah it is
quite yeah it is quite funny but
actually it's a traumatic time for me
like should I change my profession
because I totally lack inspiration like
is it the burner and I was analyzing
this situation and it was asking like
are we living in the era of 12th Collins
and three boxes like do we know any
other numbers or shapes so I was
wondering like is it only me who has
this impression or maybe the whole world
wide web has fallen into boring state
and fanfic was that I also stumble upon
this article which is from 2015 but I
still think that it's very current web
design is completely boring and it's
like yikes like what what I should do to
change it so okay I decided to take the
online detox and currently I'm reading
called coal Newport yeah call me first
book called deep work and he states that
it's very important for your mental
health and for your ideas and
concentration
stay offline so yeah hopefully this is
the remedy so I just wish Alva comuter
forget about me hands dribble sorry dad
but yeah I decided to look for the
inspiration offline so the things that
were were closes at my hand
we're old fashion magazines I got from
my friend and actually it was it so
although print medium is regarded as
that I I really found really interesting
ideas design ideas that I really wanted
to bring to the web so as you can see
like the layouts is different the
artwork so everything is carefully
assembled to support the content and I
saw that yeah this is something what we
really have to do for the web and when I
was slowly getting back to the online
word I stumble upon brutalist websites
who has ever heard about them okay so
some people so in my definition
brutalist websites are websites that are
kind of like a web nonconformists they
forget about all the existing rules
which is sometime annoying in terms of
the user experience but at the same time
it's extremely unique and it's something
what we really really need on the web
something weird something crazy and if
you think that british websites are
great for artists for portfolios for
photographers i can prove that you're
wrong because bloomberg started to use
very bold ideas and this is a really
great article and I love that they
having some gifts that look like they
look like from 2000 world art or and the
colors are very vibrant I think that's
really unique and this is a serious
article okay so now we're thinking okay
you're talking a lot about design and
print but where is the assess this is
dot CSS conference so the good news is
that I'm heading to this part after all
my ideas and
operations I decided to visit Pinterest
and look for some other images that I
can gathered and I really wanted to do
this yes as challenge and to like find
out what I can do with the code and my
like really important point was that I
wanted to keep it simple because I
really believed that CSS can bridge the
gap between designers and developers and
designers like simple things especially
when they are beginners in terms of code
so I was trying to use the most simple
code I can and the first thing that was
pretty cool for me was clipping so
clipping is just kill path which is the
shapes boundary and if I have to define
it to designers explain what is that for
me it's just like using scissors and
paper and chopping so everything that is
inside the shape is visible and and
everything that's outside is just hidden
so you might be familiar with it
that we can use different options for
clip paths we can create rectangles
circles and more sophisticated shapes
with polygons but I really like the URL
function because actually we can apply
shapes created in SVG so I created a
simple example where we have the
container and the background and
everything is clipped this is the the
the splashy shape and this is very
simple because you just have the shape
defined in SVG you can just draw it an
illustrator copy and paste it directly
in the Edit code editor you put it in
between the dev stacks because this is
the definition in SVG and later it is
referenced with in CSS and I was also
looking for different ways for clipping
how we can apply them and I thought that
maybe we can just cut out some elements
of the image what we usually do and
Photoshop for instance and save the
image later with transparency so in PNG
format so this is the example I created
I was really inspired by by collage
technique and what you can see here is
that the clip path is applied so if I
comment it up the full image is shown so
what you have to do well you have to
prepare the shape on your own so you're
starting thinking well is it better
maybe to create this PNG file but the
answer actually is the file size the PNG
with transparency weighs six times more
than JPEG with applied click Pass and
frankly speaking I don't know whether
this is the future for clipping out the
images but I do believe that this is a
great method for experiments and if you
would like to find out more about
different approach you can also check
how the priests quarters article and CSS
tricks
another great CSS feature that was super
cool for me was masking so masking is a
bit different from clipping because it
defines how the pixels will be
transparent so the mask is composited
with the image and it defines how
transparent the pixels will be so there
again different methods we can apply it
we can use raster images with
transparencies we can use gradient but
again we can use Ural function and what
I particularly love about masking is
that we can apply the same properties
just as for background so we can repeat
the background the mask we can define
its size so it is a great tools to
create interesting effects and for
masking I prepared a pretty simple
example and this is also the the example
that shows that CSS can also support
story
because it gives us some emotions but
like what the article will be about so I
can imagine that this kind of effect
would be applied in national Geographics
article or anything that is connected
with Adventures and what I do here is
just I have this whole container as a
heading h1 and the mask mask is applied
if we want to check what the masks how
the masks looks like this is it so the
the right red background is the area
that our our heading is shown so
everything was grey or white I don't
know about the conference contrast it's
actually hidden because this is the
transparent area so the last thing that
it's done is that this pan is fixed so
we have this effect of the layers and
another thing really cool about them
asking is this transparency levels and
this is the gif file where I applied a
simple mask and that's it so we can have
really really interesting in fact
without spending a lot of time and I
think that this is something that you
can show to the designers to to prove
them that CSS is a great way for
prototyping ok so now I owe you the
definition like explaining you what is
the difference between clipping and
masking so if you would like to go for
risk display the vectors it's definitely
better to go with clipping and for
masking it's wise if you would like to
have this this change of the of the
transparency levels just remember that
masking is more memory and and
computation consuming because it goes
pixels by pixel and the last thing I
want to mention is shape outside so who
said
that we need to be like our web design
used to be boxy so let's step outside of
the box literally and let's apply
different shapes so shape outside
defines how the content should be
wrapping around the floated element of
course we can we we can apply similar
values just like for masking and
clipping so we can we can have circle we
can have polygons for motor
sophisticated shapes but also there is a
URL function and this is the example I
prepared so we can see that the text
around cue letter just perfectly like
wraps around wraps around this shape and
here is a one trick because shape
outside doesn't change anything about
the the floated element itself so the
background stays as it is so if we want
to have it clipped we have to apply
either clip it'll flip path or a masking
and the important thing is that the
floated element has to have defined
either height or width to have the
coordinate system set and last thing I
want to mention is my my beloved strand
chaos it's it's really connected with
brutalist website and errors like
jamming everything that's connected with
that something is wrong it's actually
very welcomed these days in terms of web
design and I really do believe that with
with SVG yes her mentioned filters Mandy
she was talking about variable fonts
with the simple CSS tricks like clipping
and masking we can do a totally new app
and I really believe that this is in our
hand and I just have to show you the the
very last inspiration this is the
website I just like stumble upon some
word and I'll
the fact that although it's very simple
they apply the the change of the
perspective and the text is cued and I
love the fact that this is the website
that belongs to architects and I was
wondering okay how we can do this
actually it's pure CSS this is co pen
made by James Bosworth so later after my
talk about I will tweet the link so you
can check how the details so I do really
believe that the web should be more
crazy and I know that sometimes it's
very hard to encourage clients to do
brutalist website but we do have some
site projects we can try and you know
this is in our hands so whenever I
travel somewhere I try to find
inspiration for a web design and I was
visiting after demand went to stay
Tillich museum and you can just look at
the website just amazing this is the
official museum and they have British
website and the same forestry Elka
Institute I was in Moscow and I was at
this Institute and went to their website
and I suddenly fell in love it I think
it's amazing and the last thing I want
to mention is that when I was passing
when I was going to the Metro today I
just by accident so this and I think
it's amazing it's just like a basketball
court I don't know whether you live in
France but if you do and you have time
you should go there it's amazing it's
totally Instagram oval please I love the
colors the gradients everything I think
that they they're kind of like a
brutalist basketball court
and I know that it's it's hard to take
the risk but Andre Matisse he said that
creativity takes courage so we have to
take this courage and we have to
experiment and if you'd like to get some
stickers I do have the awesome stickers
with me so just come and say hi and
last thing I want to do my mom asked me
for a picture can I take a picture of
you although it's very dark but I
promised her to take to send her a
picture so it would be pretty pretty
back picture but I have a better better
idea I will do the video could you wave
yay okay perfect thank you I'll be
posting it on my Instagram it's called
the awesomes and my twitter is I can
applaud if you find then a cool
brutalist website or places in Paris
just post it I'm looking for some
inspirations and medicine
[Applause]
[Music]